episode 2 of house of the dragon has
just released with all the political
intrigue and 12 year old matchmaking
that would make even chris hansen's head
spin hey how are you good want you to
see right over there this is a massive
deep dive into the episode how it
connects to the books and lore but don't
worry there won't be any spoilers i'll
save that for a separate video so grab
your dragon and find out why my
girlfriend left me because i've been
spending too much damn time analyzing
this show before we get into the episode
i do want to talk about the intro
credits if you want to skip this part
and get right into the episode i've left
a timestamp below but i'd recommend you
stay because there are some really cool
things here so how do you follow up game
of thrones which had one of the most
iconic intros ever well you make it kind
of similar utilizing the same music and
art style but instead of us venturing
across a map it's that of a family tree
the targaryens to be exact we'll see
that the blood we follow represents the
literal bloodline of the targaryens
flowing through that giant model of old
valyria we saw king viserys working on
we start with the first chronological
event the doom of valyria you can see
these dragons with ripped wings and this
giant cracked building in the back we
learned this episode that valyria was
built on the face of a volcano and
during the doom a great cataclysm
basically turned everything to ruin
after the doom the first circle gives
way to blood leaving only the crown
aegon's crown the first targaryen ruler
in the wide shot near the end you can
see how the blood splits into three
distinct branches signifying king aegon
the first and his two sister wives
vicinia and reinice now this reynesis
depicted here is not to be confused with
the queen who never was she won't be
born for another 100 years or so now we
know this is renese by this cog which
appears to be a dragon with a spear
through its eye rhaenys's dragon maraxis
was shot by an iron bolt right through
the eye which killed both the dragon and
its rider following downward is the son
of aegon and renis aenes the first now i
think his name is pronounced aenese
unless it's of course anus in which i'm
very sorry a niece had six children with
alyssa valerian perhaps this is why we
see his line branch off however the
camera follows us to jiharis the first
and ally sane who have a whopping nine
children which you can make out all the
branches here two of the children mary
baylon and alyssa baylon was set to be
king but died before jaehaerys did with
no living sons this is what spurred
jaherus to call the great council where
the lords decided to choose his eldest
grandson viserys as next in line instead
of his granddaughter who had a more
legitimate claim you'll see baylon and
alyssa's blood break in two one for
viserys and the other for daemon now
they did have a third child named aegon
but he died before his first birthday
which might be why it isn't included
here as we continue viserys and emma
mary notice viserys's doesn't turn to
blood like emma's that's because he's
not dead throughout the intro you'll
also notice some cogs far off in the
distance some of them i weren't able to
make out because of the resolution of my
video however there's one that looks an
awful lot like it could represent
cordless valerian so my guess is that
these cogs on the periphery are members
that aren't directly in the targaryen
line which leads us to renera now this
symbol here of these three intertwined
rings is really interesting because it's
the same symbol found on the necklace
daemon gave to renera in episode 1. now
i won't spoil anything but the camera
opts not to follow what happens after
rhaenyra rather it flies through a ruin
which depicts two dragons fighting with
various houses on either side this is a
reference to the dance of dragons an
event which will shape westeros so
deeply it has implications for the
events we'll later see in game of
thrones so that's it for the intro
credits let me know about what you
thought about them in the comments below
now on to the episode to the southeast
of king's landing are the stepstones a
chain of islands that separate westeros
to the west and essos to the east this
is the area corliss valerian the king's
master of ships warned him of last
episode amirish prince craigastrahar
also known as crab feeder has taken to
routing out pirates who have long since
plagued the islands but as we'll find
out later this expedition is not without
its casualties of war corliss has
already lost one ship and crab feeder's
rule over the area could jeopardize his
lucrative trade routes something that
allowed house valerian to become the
richest in the realm after the king of
course the books never go into detail
about crab feeder's appearance so this
whole scar and mask aesthetic has been
imagined for the show i love this
transition from the blood of the
battlefield to blood red wine filling
the king's cup a cup filled by the
king's cup bearer and official heir to
the throne princess rhaenyra targaryen
as we'll find out the events of this
episode take place roughly six months
after episode 1 so some time has passed
since the death of emma and damon's
departure from the capital easy to miss
is the king's brief condolences to house
redwin on the passing of lord commander
of the kingsguard sir ryam redwin who we
saw briefly last episode he passed of
natural causes and sir harold westerling
has now taken over as lord commander but
that means there's still an empty spot
in the kingsguard which is composed of
the realm's seven finest knights sworn
to protect the king and royal family
with their lives sarim's body has been
collected by the silent sisters who
we've actually seen in the very first
episode of game of thrones surrounding
the body of robert baratheon's hand of
the king john aaron they're not to be
confused with these septas or female
priests like yunella who rang the bell
of shame these sisters take a vow of
silence which can see their mouths
covered by cloth here with a spot on the
king's card needing to be filled the
king asks his daughter to choose an
appropriate knight after all this knight
will end up becoming her personal guard
when corliss suggests they take out this
nuisance that is crab feeder the king is
yet again wary of war as lord beasbury
reminds them a war with the free cities
would come with incalculable losses
still the king has sent ships to pentos
and volantis in the hopes they may find
common cause should things get out of
hand however the king still does not see
crab feeder as a huge threat another
non-concern for the king at least for
the time being is his brother daemon the
king ordered him to return to his wife
lady raya royce in a runestone this was
an arranged marriage that was set by
their grandmother queen alisene and he
has no real love for this woman demon
has disobeyed the king's orders and hold
himself up in dragonstone where he calls
himself the prince and rightful heir the
prince or princess of dragonstone is
commonly a title only reserved for the
heir of the throne hence when rhaenyra
arrives to chew out her uncle she refers
to herself as the princess of
dragonstone later in the episode damon
will invite his brother to his wedding
with massaria it's not without precedent
that targaryen ancestors could take more
than one wife in fact king maegor had
six wives rhaenyra chimes in and
suggests they could use their dragons
but this out of turn remark is shot down
by her father if renee is going to
become queen one day she must learn her
place
you will learn in the courtyard rhaenyra
must choose a suitable replacement for
sir ryan and otto has hand-picked a
number of candidates i like the nice
little touch of reneira needing a step
stool to appear above the banister a
visual representation for how much she
still has to learn in front of her are
seven nights from various houses from
left to right house karen mallister
corbrey rowan craighall cole and tarly i
hope this tarly wasn't the same one who
got completely decimated at the
tournament six months ago you'll notice
that sir kristen cole here is the only
one without a bannerman this could be
because he is simply the son of a common
born a steward to lord dondarrion you
might remember beric dondarrion from
game of thrones is a descendant of this
house watching from afar is princess
rhaenys the queen who never was she'll
later share some choice words with
renera about how the realm really works
rhaenyra is only interested in sir
kristen cole the man who bested her
uncle at the tournament and to whom she
gave her favor to in episode 1. he is
the only man in the group who has
actually seen real battle a trait she
believes necessary in order to become a
member of the kingsguard however one
can't deny that there may be some
romantic interest here as well sir
kristin fought against the dornish
incursion one of the seven kingdoms
which at this time in targaryen history
has not been fully conquered it won't be
until another 70 years or so until dorne
bends the knee and officially comes
under targaryen rule otto gets a taste
of rhaenyra's stubbornness when she
chooses sir kristen over other knights
who may have been a better choice
politically it's a little warning that
she may not be as easy to control as her
father becerras works on his hobby
modeling this giant recreation of the
capital of old valyria he's kind of like
that guy who's really into trains he
tells alison that just like dragonstone
the capital was built on the face of a
volcano close to the source of their
magic and power whether we'll ever see
westeros harness the amount of power
that old valyria did before it was
destroyed by the doom is yet to be known
however the breaking of one of his
models is not the most positive
foreshadowing alison makes an effort to
repair the relationship between viserys
and rhaenyra telling both in separate
conversations that they should make an
effort to open up and talk to each other
since emma's death and rhaenyra's
announcement as heir the two have
drifted further apart at a sept in
king's landing not to be confused with
the great sept of bailor we saw in game
of thrones which hasn't been built yet
renera expresses her concerns over being
air not only is her father being
pressured to wed and have new heirs but
she feels being chosen as hair had more
to do with spurning damon than it did
with her being wanted for the job at its
core renera wants to be seen than more
than just a little girl in the gardens
outside the red keep corliss and raynese
set the stage on why it's more important
than ever to show the realm is strong
the queen has passed a girl has been
made heir the king's brother has claimed
dragonstone without challenge and a
foreign power has established a colony
in their most critical of shipping lanes
fun fact when the king refers to rhaenys
as his favorite cousin it's kind of a
joke considering she's his only living
cousin corliss suggests the best way to
show this strength is for the king to
wed their 12 year old daughter lena a
match that would link the two strongest
houses of westeros and prove to the
people that the kingdom's strongest days
are ahead of them both the grand maester
and master of laws lionel strong approve
of this match lana is the eldest
daughter of the richest house made of
unpeachable valerian stock and also has
targaryen blood otto of course has his
reservations as he's been quietly
scheming to get his daughter closer to
the king the king's finger also seems to
be suffering from the same mysterious
ailment we've seen on his back both his
back and finger were cut from the iron
throne and nothing seems to be healing
these wounds it really becomes a
metaphor for how the throne is both
literally and figuratively killing him
in what i found to be the most
disturbing scene of this episode was the
king and 12 year old lena's walk through
the garden the king can easily see that
this poor girl has been coached by her
parents on what to say we'll later find
out that rhaenys hates this match too
seeing your 12 year old wed to an old
man who's your cousin isn't exactly
every mom's dream unless of course we're
watching an episode of honey boo boo she
even had to tell her daughter that she
likely wouldn't have to bed him until
she was 14. creepiness aside there's
some interesting talk of dragons here
mainly that of vegar for those of you
who have read the books you'll know why
this is important and why elena is
bringing this up veigar's whereabouts
are currently unknown but rumor suggests
she lives somewhere on the coast of the
narrow sea renis and rhaenyra have a
rocky relationship there's probably some
resentment here from the queen who never
was since rhaenyra will have the chance
to be queen when she never did but
renese's warnings however biting they
may be are practical the king will be
forced to wed likely have a male child
and that child will become king even
though lords from across the realm swore
fealty to her rhaenys reminds ranira men
would sooner put the round to the torch
and see a woman ascend the iron throne
at dinner both viserys and alison are
nervous viserys plays with his food and
alcent picks at her fingernails we saw
her do this multiple times including at
the tournament last episode alicent has
a special gift no it's not her virginity
it's something even better his repaired
dragon although i was joking about the
virginity thing it's heavily implied
that before otto goes off to dragonstone
that he instructs his daughter that
tonight is the night for her to make a
move in the king's bedchamber she is
super nervous about this as you can tell
by her fingernails which otto remarks on
otto is oblivious to the anxiety and
stress he is putting on his daughter an
emergency small council meeting is
called where a dragon tamer reports that
prince damon has taken a dragon egg from
the dragon pit the dragon tamer refers
to it being stolen during the hour of
the bat in the world of game of thrones
there are several of these named hours
with that of the bat being a just after
sunset missoria is with child and as is
tradition the egg will be put in the
cradle for this future targaryen
rhaenyra wants to know which egg her
uncle took and it just so happens to be
the same one that was chosen for her
brother's cradle this is an egg from
dream fire who we haven't yet seen in
the show with it being deemed unsafe for
the king to ride off to dragonstone otto
along with sir harold westerling and
kristen cole confront the prince he is
to relinquish the egg disband his army
composed of loyal gold cloaks banish
massaria and leave a dragonstone but
damon doesn't give up that easily he
even calls sir kristen sir crispin in
demon's mind he hasn't done anything
wrong he has the right to take a new
wife it's tradition to take an egg for
his child and dragonstone is the home of
his ancestors there is this great line
where daemon proclaims that massari is
to be his wife but she looks to him like
i never knew that as we'll soon realize
both the wife and child claim were a
complete bluff the standoff appears to
be at a standstill until renera arrives
on her dragon cyrax she reminds her
uncle that dragonstone is hers and that
if he wants it for himself and to be
restored as heir he'll need to kill her
of course damon's not a monster and he
stands down throwing the egg to raniera
as if it's nothing it's important to
note here that the writers aren't trying
to portray damon as a senseless monster
there is some humanity to him and he
does love his family damon's a
complicated guy but he's not a monster i
mean this is his family he does love his
family particularly loves rhaenyra i
actually think rainer earned a lot of
respect from her uncle here remember
that damon thinks his brother is weak
and renera showing this amount of
strength proves that she'd one day make
a great queen as rhaenyra flies off on
her dragon we get this brief shot of
otto who's like uh oh this could become
a problem mysteria tears into daemon
about what just happened her entire life
she's been a pawn of men and thought
being with damon would be different
using her as part of his lies has only
confirmed that damon is just like the
rest of them massaria tells him that she
quote insured long ago that i would
never be threatened by childbirth which
i took to mean that she did something so
she could never have children in the
books she actually is pregnant with
damon's child but loses it during a
storm on the narrow sea after being
forced to return to her home perhaps
this change was done to show just how
duplicitous and cunning damon is so i'm
really curious where damon's
relationship with massari will go after
this big difference from the book with
missouri's statement that she hoped
damon would liberate her from fear it'll
be interesting to see what he plans to
do to rectify this relationship in a
special meeting with lionel strong
master of laws the king gets his opinion
on who to wed lena in strong's opinion
is the clear choice while the scene
doesn't offer anything really new about
viserys's options it does reinforce how
difficult a decision this is and how
almost everyone around him supports it
minus otto of course who never
explicitly states an opinion on the
matter this will be viserys's second
huge decision that will go against what
the other lords of the realm would want
the first being his decision to name a
female as heir rhaenyra is brought to
her father to answer for her dangerous
antics at dragonstone notice here that
she is now being guarded by sir kristen
cole viserys was dreadfully worried
about his daughter his only heir and for
the first time in months the two
actually have a beneficial conversation
where they each talk about their
feelings and how emma's death has
affected them viserys tells her that
emma's absence is like a wound that will
never heal an apt analogy considering he
now has two physical wounds that won't
heal the most important line here
however is that viserys has no intention
on replacing rhaenyra as heir which i
implied as meaning even if the king does
have a male heir with a new queen that
renera will still become queen this
obviously will ruffle a lot of feathers
should this play out the scene ends with
ronira understanding that the king's
first duty is to the realm and she's
fine with him taking on a new wife the
king overlooks his realm the weight of
the decision he's about to make clearly
on his mind he has chosen alicent as his
queen and to mary before spring ends it
seems otto's plot to position his
daughter near the king during his
greatest time of need has paid off of
course corliss is pissed and leaves
before he says anything that could get
his head chopped off so too does
rhaenyra both her father and best friend
never told her about any of this for
rhaenyra it's got to feel like a
betrayal and now her best friend is
going to become her mom at what is
likely driftmark the home of house
valerian corliss has a secret meeting
with prince damon you can see just how
close driftmark is to dragonstone it
would have been a quick flight for the
prince to make corliss talks about how
the valyrians have a greater claim to
westeros arriving there even before the
targaryens but the targaryens had
something that always made them superior
the dragons he propositions damon to
join forces and venture to the
stepstones to take on crab feeder it's a
mutually beneficial alliance corliss
gets to protect his vital shipping lanes
and daemon can prove his worth to anyone
who may doubt it the episode ends with
this great juxtaposition of crab feeder
and daemon hinting at the clash of these
two princes to come now there's still a
lot to talk about in regards to this
episode and my plan is if hbo releases a
promo video for next episode for me to
do a breakdown of that where i'll
include the book spoilers you'll want to
be subscribed with the bell on to be
notified as soon as that drops thanks
for watching everyone be sure to like
and subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
it's a crispin wasn't it